Jeff is in Boise Idaho hi Jeff how are
you I'm about like I deserve but I'm
working on it how are you good for you
sir I love it uh what is your net worth
sir 1.5 about of that about 250 K is the
house okay cool what's the rest of it
that's all retirement funds mutual funds
Mutual's in in like a 401 k and that
kind of stuff yes sir 403 401 some of
its pension funds represents a cash
value but it's all kind of turned in
there how old are you I don't get to I'm
57 57 years old right and what has been
your range of income through your
working life would you start at and what
was your best year and that kind of
stuff uh the year I got my commission in
the Navy I made twelve thousand bucks
but that was about two lifetimes ago I'm
up around 90 now okay cool and what do
you do for a living I'm a mechanical
engineer okay not very cool how much of
the one and a half million dollars did
you inherit nine zero okay so you didn't
hear how much of it did you steal Oh
none you know what I just thought I'd
check cuz you know yeah alright so you
got a degree in mechanical engineering
I'm guessing yes sir okay and what was
your GPA getting your degree um 2.75
first time we run okay alright and how
much of this wealth is there because you
borrowed money to create wealth not a
okay not a dime right and what part has
giving played in your financial plan
over these years would for me the big
thing is that now that I've kind of
broken through and smart about this
thing is it frees me up to give um you
know we've always given some might
contribute to Yusef what about programs
around here and retired military or
disabled military people this is what
you know was a nickel here and nickel
there and what we could afford
well now that now that we've kind of
broken the barrier it really opens up
the possibilities yeah you live like no
one else later you can live and give
like no one else so there's so much they
called me that about six years ago I'm
sorry
somebody told me that about six years
ago and that's when I finally figured it
out I love it cool what's the most
expensive pair of jeans you or your wife
ever bought 25 bucks
Cabela's or Walley world one of the two
before you were a millionaire
how many brand-new cars did you buy two
regretted both of them okay cool cool so
uh you're talking to the 25 year old
version of you that's listening right
now number one can they still do it or
is the dream gone in America oh the
dreams alive
how would that do it what would you tell
them to do my words to myself in a B
start sooner stupid so what did you do
how did you mean what would you say that
you attribute being a one-and-a-half
millionaire to being stubborn and
picking with what works
consistent saving is that what you're
saying
yeah they're okay in your 401k and good
mutual funds and then you got the house
paid off and that's almost all of it hey
thank you for your service to our
country we appreciate that thank you for
being an economic hero and proving it
can still be done in America and thanks
for sharing your story this is a
millionaire theme our hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
you
Oh